thank you
but he coaches
yeah yeah you gotta stay on the mic okay
what do you want can you shoot something
for me yeah you guys five-point game oh
man you almost turned that might be it
yeah
what happened you was with us for like
10 seconds at least I did what I had to
do I gave you eight minutes take
advantage I tried to tell you which
sometimes type of dudes
oh wow
oh my God in front of company
[Applause]
[Music]
Fat Joe dropped the mic
[Applause]
did they count it wait a minute hold on
I saw one of the officials wave it off
wait a minute
[Applause]
Giannis says his team wanted team Dwayne
Bedlam at Mid Court
oh it's a final the bucket does not
count and team Dwayne wins it one more
look
the ball was still
in biz's hand at the expiration of the
clock right there you can see it
you gotta count that just because we
having so much fun man oh man
Fat Joe while over here brought his team
back from the brink of defeat and
Giannis antetenicumpo the NBA Finals MVP
waving it off there Hazel's going the
opposite way Lisa Leslie wanted it to
count they lobbied the officials and
Giannis ended up winning the debate
taking his ball and going home yeah it's
over if Yana says and what did Fat Joe
have to say
speechless he had nothing to say it was
over that was crazy
oh my God
sweat's coming off of me
got Wheaties for everybody now